جمال طبعا التطورات تتواتر اخرها بطبيعه
الحال الاخبار العاجله التي تبرز وهو عن
استهداف استود ومدن ومناطق اسرائيليه في
غلاف غز الى جانب طبعا المواجهات المستمره
من الشمال الى الجنوب كلها سنحلها مع
اللواء فيزير الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ولكن اولا اليك سلام لنطلع على الخارطه
على توزع وبل توزيع والمواجهات اين تتركز
تحديدا في شكرا جلال وسنبدا بالخ الذي
انتهت منه قبل قليل النشره بان فصائل
المقاومه تطلق دفعه سرايا القدس تطلق دفعه
من الصواريخ على عده مناطق في غلاف غزه
هذا ينقلنا الى انتقاد رئيسي دوما ما
توجهه مراكز الابحاث بالتحديد
الامريكيه معهد السلام الامريكي في واشنطن
كان قد قال ان واحده من اوجه الخلل التي
اتسمت فيها هذه العمليه برمتها هي هي ان
اسرائيل فشلت باستقراء القدرات الحقيقيه
لحركه حماس لكتائب القسام بالتحديد ولباقي
فصائل المقاومه والصواريخ هذه تاتي ضمن
هذه النقطه بالتحديد بسبب واضح لان
اسرائيل تقول انها دمرت اكثر من 700 منصه
صواريخ وقبل قليل كنت اتحدث مع اللواء
دويري قال لي من غير المعقول ان تكون
المقاومه قد وضعت كل المنصات الصواريخ
الاساس لديها فوق الارض اللواء دويري
يعتقد بان غالبيه ترسانه الاسلحه البعيده
وايضا الصواريخ ليست فوق الارض في قطاع
غزه غالبيتها تحت الارض وربما هذا الامر
على الاغلب صحيح لاننا اليوم راينا هذه
الدفعه قبل قليل بالتزامن مع الاعلان
الاسرائيلي الى جنوب القطاع جنوب القطاع
لا يزال يشهد معارك مستمره وما زالت مدينه
خان يونس هي هي واحده من النقاط الاكثر
اشتعالا قوات الاحتلال تحاول التوغل عميقا
الى داخل المدينه هناك مقاومه صلبه جدا
تواجهها ويتم ايضا استهداف التجمعات حيث
تتواجد تجمعات وايضا استهداف الجنود وقوات
المشاه في الجنوب هناك اكثر من ثمانيه
الويه يقاتلون وبالتالي هناك قدره على
استخدام الطائرات المقاتله امس على سبيل
المثال استد اسرائيل الطائرات او الوحدات
الميدانيه الطائرات لتضرب اهداف داخل
مدينه خانيونس لم تتمكن من التوغل فيها
ولكن هذا الاستخدام يبقى محدود بسبب ان
الجنود تقدموا والاليات تقدموا قدره
الطائرات المسلحه او المقاتله على على
القيام وتنفيذ استهدافات تكون يعني دقيقه
بعض الشيء خشيه من تكرار ما يحدث معهم في
بعض الاماكن من استهداف بالدبابات لجنوده
الى المنطقه الوسطى لا تزال ايضا مشتعله
ولكن نصيرات البريج المغازي وقصف على دير
البلح ولكن هناك ايضا على ما يبدو قوه
اسرائيليه عالقه في هذه المنطقه يتم
استهدافها من قبل فصائل المقاومه الختام
في الشمال هناك ايضا عوده لما نسميه
الاحزمه الناريه وهو القصف المكثف في نقطه
متركزه بسلسله من الغارات او استهداف
المدفعي تهدف بشكل اساسي للتدمير الممنهج
هذه جلال ابرز الامور التي تحدث وحدثت في
قطاع غزه القراءه معك واللواء دويري ان
المعلومه التي زودك بها عن المنصات اتابع
معه اللواء دويري رشقه صاروخيه جديده
باتجاه ادود ومدن ومناطق اسرائيليه بينما
اسرائيل تتحدث عن تدمير اعداد كبيره من
منصات اطلاق الصواريخ في قطاع غزه يعني
دعنا نفرق بين المنصه والصاروخ الان رقم
700 اذا ارتبط بالمنصات فاعتقد انه رقم
مبالغ في هذه الروايه الاسرائيليه اعتقد
انه رقم مبالغ فيه لكن اذا تحدثنا عن
الصواريخ تم اطلاق 3200 صاروخ في اليوم
الاول وبالتالي هذا الرقم متواضع لماذا
لانه اصلا الارقام غير معروفه يعني
التقديرات الواش نيويورك تايمز بان مخزون
حماس بعد انتهاء ال 21 كان 50,000 صاروخ
الواشنطن بوست قدرت في 35 ال صاروخ لاحظ
التباين ما بين صحيفتين يعني لديهما نفوذ
واسع ومسائل كثيره للحصول على المعلومه
كانت هذا الفجوه 15000 صاروخ وبالتالي منذ
ال 21 حتى طوفان الاقصى عمليه التصنيع
مستمره فلو اعتمدنا حتى الرقم الادنى قد
يكون لديهم 60 70 الف صاروخ كم اطلق منه
لكن عندما نتحدث على المنصات لا شاهدنا في
بعض الفيديوهات وان كانت قبل طوفان الاقصى
لكن كانت هي اي تعبر عن ماذا لدى القسام
شاهدنا منصات اطلاق كبيره تطلق 16 صاروخ
في الرشق الواحده
وتدفع على عجلات او على سكه هذه لن تكون
فوق سطح الارض في ظل الهيمنه او السيطره
الجويه المطلقه ل لجيش الاحتلال وبالتالي
يجب ان تكون في الانفاق كما هم المقاتلين
في الانفاق اذا لانه احن المعركه الرئيسيه
هي معركه انفاق
ولكن لانه انطلاقها من الانفاق وتنفيذها
على سطح الارض وبالتالي الصواريخ تنطلق من
تحت الارض والمقاتل يخرج من تحت الارض طيب
المشاهد يسال في بعض الاحيان وعندما نلتقي
بالناس يسالونا هل تراجع حده اطلاق
الصواريخ من قطاع غزه تعني بالضروره بان
منصه
الصواريخ تضررت يعني ماذا ماذا تقرا
باستراتيجيه اطلاق الصواريخ قطاع غزه بعد
99 يوم من القصف الجوي واكثر من 65 يوم من
القتال البري هل يعقل ان منصات الصواريخ
لم
تتضرر اكيد الاجابه قطعا لا حصل ضرر ولكن
اليس قبل ثلاثه ايام تم اطلاق صواريخ على
تل ابيب لكن الان ومن الشمال نعم الان
السؤال لماذا انخفض مستوى اطلاق الصوا هذا
ندف استراتيجيا الى ماذا استراتيجيا انا
ساجيبك من بعد تحليلي الان هل نهايه الحرب
معروفه هل يستطيع اي شخص ان يقول ستنتهي
الحرب يوم 1 اثين من الشهر القادم لا احد
يستطيع الاجابه لانه كره ثلج
م تتدحرج تكبر باتجاهات متعدده يعني كانت
على وشك الوصول الى اتفاقيه جديده نفذت
عمليه
الاغت الاغتيال في بيروت خلطت الاوراق من
جديد اذا دعي يعني اقول لا يوجد رؤيه
واضحه فبالتالي المخطط الاستراتيجي في
القسام وغيرها عليه ان يخطط لاسوا سيناريو
يمكن ان يواجهه وبالتالي الم يكن الحديث
الجان باسرائيل الحرب قد تستمر لاشهر اذا
هو عليه ان يخطط هذا بعد البعد الاخر اكيد
تم الحاق الضرر ببعض الانفاق ببعض المنصات
وبالتالي هذه الاجابه القاطعه هي لدى
المسؤول او قائد لوى الصواريخ في القسام
نحن تحليليا قد نصيب نخط اصلا اصلا تقارير
امريكيه قالت بان على ما يبدو طريقه اطلاق
الفصائل الفلسطينيه للصواريخ يبدو بانها
مستعده لمرحله طويله من الحرب بطبيعه
الحال هذه الصور التي نتابعها ايضا من غزه
قبل ايام لاحظنا اللواء الدويري منذ
تقريبا اسبوع او اكثر قليلا عشره ايام
عادت اسرائيل لاستخدام البوارج الحربيه
لاطلاق قذائف باتجاه قطاع غزه من بد منذ
بدء معركه المخيمات دعني يسميها معركه
المخيمات منطقه الوسط وفي الاسبوع الثاني
وبدايه الاسبوع الثالث من هذه المعركه
امتدت الم لانه في بدايه المعارك حوالي 10
ايام كانت البريج لوحدها ا ومن ثم انتقلت
الى نصيرات والمغازي
وبالتالي الان منذ بدات تلك المعركه تدخل
سلاح البحريه لجيش الاحتلال بالقصف اليومي
لكن الان الحسابات لا اكثر من عمليات
القصف هناك توقع لعمليات انزال بحري سواء
في مقابل نصيرات او مقابل دير البلح وحتى
هناك اشارات قد يكون مقابل رفح اذا هناك
ثلاثه مناطق متوقع ان يقوم جيش الاحتلال
بتنفيذ عمليات الابرار او الانزال البحري
وهذا اجراء طبيعي
بالنسبه هو هو هو اجراء استثنائي لانه
المعركه الارضيه لا تسير وفق خطه واضحه
فبالتالي لا بد من ارباك المدافع ولا بد
من الزج بقوات سواء كانت بريه او بحريه من
اتجاهات مختلفه من اجل تشتيت الجهد وهذا
ما يجري من مساء هذا اليوم كقراء
استراتيجيه عامه من ساعات ما قبل المساء
بدات يحدث تغيرات على الارض هذه التغيرات
اولها الان طريق شارع صلاح الدين تم
اندفاع سريه من المنطقه الفاصله بين
الزوايده والمغازي
باتجاه دير البلح ووصلت الى المستشفى وهي
تقريبا سريه بابات يضاف الى ذلك في جنو في
المنطقه الجنوبيه لو سمحتي نذهب الى منطقه
خان يونس
هناك في منطقه القراره والزن تم سحب
القوات منطقه جنوب بني سهيلا الفخاري
هناك اندفاع بحجم لواء اندفع ساعات ما ما
قبل
المغرب بالاصل هو قبل 48 ساعه وحاول ان
يصل الى منطقه يطلق عليها قازان النج
الى جنوب شرق خانون قازان النجار وفشلت
المحاوله الاولى في ساعات المساء من هذا
اليوم دفع بلواء مدرع كامل من من جنوب
عبسان الكبيره بهذا الاتجاه واستطاع
الوصول الى منطقه قازان النجار لكن حتى
هذه الساعه لا نقول انه دخلها لا نقول انه
سيطر عليها لكنه احاط بها والان بدات
معركه قد تكون شديده جدا في قريه قازان
النجار لماذا قازان النجار لانها توصل الى
ما يطلق عليها الكليه العلميه التطبيقيه
وهي بالتالي يبدا يدخل خان يونس من الجنوب
والجنوب الشرقي يضاف الى ذلك انه بدا الان
بضغط كبير جدا لو عدنا لو سمحت الى منطقه
المخيمات
بدا بضغط كبير جدا الان في اللحظات اللي
انا بتحدث فيها هناك ضغط كبير جدا على
مخيم الزوايده وعلى مخيم المغازي وهو قصف
الزوايد اليوم بالبوار الحربيه نعم الان
لا لا في الساعات ال انا وهل الان وانا
اتحدث معك اقول لك تجري معارك ضاريه وقصف
جوي شديد جدا على مخيم الزوايده وعلى مخيم
المغازي فيما خم خفل حده القصف على البريج
والنصيرات لكن بقي القصف على البريج وان
سيرات من اجل اجبار الوحدات وطبعا هناك
قصف
وهناك معارك ارضيه في شمال شرق البريج في
شمال غرب نصيرات هذا الضغط لكنه اقل من
الضغط السابق انا كتحليل اقول هو يحاول ان
يديم الضغط على البريج والنصيرات ليمنع
كتائب البريج والنصيرات من تعزيز البريج
من تعزيز المغازي والسيارات من تعزيز
الزوايده لانه اذا سيطر على الزوايده واو
اذا يعني دخل الى الزوايده والمغازي وهي
مخيمات صغيره تنفتح اله الطريق باتجاه دير
البلح وبالتالي كاني ارى ان معركه دير
البلح قد تحدث خلال ال 24 او ال 48 ساعه
القادمه لا اختم موضوع الانزال البحري
الانزال البحري يكون عاده فقط
لمشاهب لا يمكن انزال اليه لا يمكن حسب
طبيعه حسب طبيعه المعديات يعني يمكن ان
نسل سياره عندك معديات تحمل سفن سوري تحمل
دبابات تحمل اليات برمائيه الات يعني يمكن
ان يدفع بجهد ق نسميه ثانويا او مساندا من
البحر من اجل تشتيت الجهد وتشتيت الانتباه
نلاحظ في الجبهه الشماليه اللواء دويري
استخدام الطائرات المسيره لاطلاق النار او
القنص بدل القوه الراجله هل
بدات تتلمس ما قالت اسرائيل بانها المرحله
الثالثه من الحرب الاسرائيليه في الشان
بدا توظيف الكوات كابتور في المنطقه
الشماليه المسيره الصغيره الصغيره ولكنها
مسلح
تقوم بدور اطلاق العيارات الطلقات الناريه
وتقوم بدور القناصه مسممه الكترونيا ولها
برمجيه خاصه تقصف اي هدف متحرك هذه بدات
استخدامها في المنطقه الشماليه وتستخدمها
بصوره على نطاق واسع جدا في منطقه شرق هان
يونس في بني سيله بسبب صعوبه المعركه هنا
هناك لتتبع اي مقاتل يظهر بينما هنا لانه
اصبحت عمليات العمليات القتاليه في شرق
خان يونس مكلفه جدا باهظه جدا وخسائر
الجيش الاحتلال كبيره فبالتالي بدا يوظف
طائرات الكوات كوبتر حتى لتن لا اقول لتحل
محل القناصين انما لتساعد وتقلل من
استخداماتهم لانه في الافلام السابقه كان
القناص من القسام يستهدف القناص
الاسرائيلي وشاهدنا اكثر من فيلم حول ذلك
وحتى من من ياتي ليساعد الذي تم قنصه ايضا
ايضا ستهدف للم تلجا الى هذه الطائرات
الصغيره ما الذي لاحظته من تغير
بتكتيكات الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ تم الاعلان
عن ما تسميها اسرائيل المرحله الثالثه من
الح في
المرحله دعنا نقول المنطقه الوسطى
والجنوبيه مزج بين النار والمناوره يعني
يعني كان يهاجم على سبيل المثال عندما
هاجم المخيمات ان سيرات البريج وثم انتقل
الى الزوايده د فع بقوه ارت بموازاه شارع
الرشيد الى الغرب من النصيرات والزوايده
وانعطف باتجاه الشرق من اجل فصل الزوايده
عن المغازي بينما عمليات المناوره كانت في
بدايه المرحله الاولى عندما دخلت من وادي
غزه ومن شارع الرشيد من الشمال والتقيا في
منطقه دخلا من منطقه توام وتجاه مجمع شفاء
والتقيا على شارع النصر الان طبيعه الارض
تسمح هنا اجرى اكثر من من عمليه المناوره
دخل من كوس فيم وصل قطع لو سمحت الخارطه
القسم الجنوبي دخل من كوس فيم و قطع شارع
صلاح الدين تحرك
باتجاه القراره انعطف
باتجاه المطاحن اندفع باتجاه ابو هولي
باتجاه مدينه الحمد وصل الى جوش قطيف
وتثبت في تلك المنطقه وحقق تماس في ثلاثه
نقاط مع داخل مدينه غزه منطقه الكتيبه
والسجن والمحطه لكنه في الجنوب تعثر العمل
اكثر مما يجب ودفع باكثر من مره بقوات
لكنه هذا اليوم نجح من خلال لواء كامل ان
يصل الى اي قيزان النجار طيب سنعرض صور
بثت سر القدس مشاهد من تفجير عناصرها حقل
الغام واستهداف خط مسير قوه بشات
اسرائيليه جنوب وشرق مدينه غزه كما نتابع
في هذه اللقطات لسيار القدس اللواء
الدويري
ما تحليلك يعني الان هذا عمليات تفخيخ
لعمليات واضح الكيبل نعم الكيبل او
الكورتكس عم عمليات التفخيخ وكان يحمل
اناء ويحمل معه سائل معين يعني في بعض
الحالات قد يستغرب المشاهد هناك متفجرات
مائع او سائله ليست كل المتفجرات صلبه
هناك تفجرات الواطيه ما يسمى الباودر ملح
البارود هناك المتفجرات
العجين المتفجرات العاليه العجين
البلاستيكيه للاساس التي ان تي وطورت الى
انواع متعدده وهناك قد تكون لديك متفجرات
سائله مائع لزجه هي ليست سائله بمعنى
سائله لججه
لانها يدخل في تركيبها مواد متعدده لن لن
اذكرها ولكن نفس المفعول تقر ن نعم تعطي
مفعول قوي يعني لن ادخل بتفصيلات على
الهوا واضح اذا هذه الصور التي نتابعها
وواضح ان هناك جنود اسرائيليون وتم
استهدافهم من قبل سرايا القط
بحسب هذه الصور التي حصلت عليها الجزيره
الواء دويري نحن عشيه 100 يوم على الحرب
سيكون لدينا تغطيه خاصه وسنتحدث اكثر عن
ما الذي حققه كل كل طرف بعد مرور 100 يوم
على الحرب والقصف لقطاع غزه والتدمير
والعديد من الشهداء والجرحى شكرا للواء
فيز ويري الخبير العسكري واستراتيجي جماع